Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. On the second day of the month of January, I saw the royal banner of your highnesses raised by force of arms on the towers of the Alhambra, which is the fortress of Granada, and saw the Moorish king come to the gates of the said city and kiss the royal hands of your highnesses and of my lord the prince. And thereafter, in that same month, your highnesses, as Catholic Christians, and as princes who love the holy Christian faith, and as augmenters thereof and foes of the sect of Muhammad, and of all idolatries and heresies, thought of sending me, Christopher Columbus, to the regions of India. And your highness has
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》（The Rest Is History）。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在一月二日那天，我看到你们殿下的皇家旗帜，以武力在阿尔罕布拉宫的塔楼上升起，阿尔罕布拉宫就是格拉纳达的要塞，我看到摩尔人国王来到该城的城门前，亲吻了你们殿下以及我主亲王的皇家之手。此后，在同月，你们殿下作为天主教徒、热爱神圣天主教信仰的君王、其传播者以及穆罕默德邪说和所有偶像崇拜与异端的敌人，考虑派遣我，克里斯托弗·哥伦布，前往印度地区。并且你们殿下
ordered that I should not travel overland to the east as is customary, but rather by way of the west, whether to this day, as far as we can know for certain, no man has ever gone before. But Dominic was, of course, Christopher Columbus, he named himself in that letter, writing to Ferdinand and Isabella, king and queen of what was soon to become Spain, the United Kingdom of Spain. And in the first episode, we described that great scene where he goes to Granada, which has just fallen to the Spanish forces. Columbus thinks that his project to sail to the New World has been dismissed by Ferdinand and Isabella, sets off sadly on his mule, and then gets called back and told that actually Ferdinand and Isabella are willing to sponsor this seemingly madcap scheme to head to China and India, heading not east, as he said in that letter, but westwards across the Atlantic. So what is the process by which he, following that meeting, following that commission, he is able to set sail on this historic voyage?
下令让我不要像通常那样经由陆路向东旅行，而是经由西方，直到今天据我们所知，过去从未有人曾从那里走过。但多米尼克，他当然就是克里斯托弗·哥伦布，他在那封信中这样称呼自己，写信给费迪南德和伊莎贝拉，即不久将成为西班牙的国王和女王、西班牙联合王国的君主。在第一集中，我们描述了那个伟大的场景：他前往刚刚落入西班牙军队之手的格拉纳达。哥伦布认为他航行到新世界的计划已经被费迪南德和伊莎贝拉拒绝了，他伤心地骑着骡子出发，然后被叫回去，并被告知实际上费迪南德和伊莎贝拉愿意资助这个看似异想天开的计划，前往中国和印度，不向东走——正如他在那封信中所说——而是向西横跨大西洋。那么，在他那次会面、那份委任之后，他能够踏上这次历史性航程的过程是什么呢？
Well, hello, everybody. It's a great letter, actually, Tom. It's a great way to kick off because it establishes us very firmly in the world of late medieval Spain, of the Reconquista, of the obsession with Islam. And it captures the vagueness to some extent of Columbus's project, doesn't it? He talks about the Indies, but is he going to the Indies or to Cathay or to Japangu, Japan? But Indies is not the same as India, is it? I mean, Indies is a kind of- He's very vague. He's deliberately very vague because the truth is he doesn't really know. So as you say, they've given him the commission at long last. He's been touting around his idea like a tech entrepreneur trying to get venture capital. And now they've
嗯，大家好。这真是一封很棒的信，汤姆。这是一个很好的开端，因为它非常坚定地将我们置于中世纪晚期西班牙的世界里，置于收复失地运动中，置于对伊斯兰教的痴迷中。而且它在某种程度上捕捉到了哥伦布计划的模糊性，不是吗？他谈到了印度，但他要去的是印度、契丹还是日本？但“Indies”和“India”并不是一回事，对吧？我的意思是，“Indies”是一种——他非常模糊。他故意非常模糊，因为事实是他自己也不是真的很清楚。所以正如你所说，他们终于给了他委任。他一直在像一个寻求风险投资的技术创业者一样兜售他的想法。现在他们已经
given him permission. He takes about three months to get ready. He goes down to the port of Palos de la Frontera, which is on the coast of Huelva in the southwest of Spain. He has money from a consortium of Genoese and Florentine bankers who are largely based in Seville. So they've given him more than a million maravedis, which is the Spanish currency. So he's in this port called Palos, and he basically is recruiting from that area. Because he gets told, doesn't he, by Ferdinand and Isabella that he can take convicts. That's right. But in the end, he doesn't need to because he signs up lots of people from Huelva.
给了他许可。他花了大约三个月的时间做准备。他南下去了巴罗斯德拉夫龙特拉港，它位于西班牙西南部的韦尔瓦海岸。他的资金来自一群热那亚和佛罗伦萨的银行家财团，他们主要总部设在塞维利亚。因此，他们给了他一百多万马拉维迪，这是当时的西班牙货币。所以他身处这个名为巴罗斯的港口，基本上是在该地区招募人员。因为费迪南德和伊莎贝拉告诉他，他可以带罪犯，不是吗？没错。但最后，他并不需要这样做，因为他签下了许多来自韦尔瓦的人。
Well, what he does is he gets in with a group of brothers from the area. So they're called the Pindon brothers. So there's Martin, there's Vicente, and there is Francisco. They are well known in the area. They are experienced mariners. They bring people on board. And this is not a big expedition by any means. So there are three fairly small, about 100 tons at maximum, caravels as they're called. By comparison, the ships that Columbus would have sailed on as a very young man, the big Genoese trading ships, are 10 times heavier.
好吧，他所做的是他与该地区的一群兄弟混在了一起。他们被称为平松兄弟。所以有马丁，有比森特，还有弗朗西斯科。他们在当地很有名。他们是有经验的水手。他们把人们带上船。这绝不是一次规模宏大的探险。因此，有三艘相当小的、最大约100吨的帆船，也就是所谓的轻型快船。相比之下，哥伦布年轻时航行过的大型热那亚商船要重上10倍。
So these are small, light. They're kind of round, basically, aren't they? Yeah, very maneuverable ships. Famously, Tom, as you will know, with a mixture of square and triangular rigging. We discussed that in the previous episode. We did indeed. So the Pindons bring on about 90 people with them. And they've got three ships.
所以这些船很小，很轻。它们基本上是圆的，对吧？是的，非常灵活的船只。汤姆，正如你所知，它们具有方帆和三角帆混合的索具，这是出了名的。我们在上一集中讨论过这一点。确实如此。所以平松兄弟带了大约90人上船。他们有三艘船。
So famously, lots of our American listeners will know this by heart because they'll have studied this in elementary school, the Niña, the Pinta, and the Santa Maria. The Niña is called the Girl, but it actually has its nickname because its owner is a guy called Juan Niño. The Pinta, probably named after the Pindindon brothers who are the big cheeses uh and the santa maria obviously the um it's kind of the holy mary i suppose that that would be what's mary the crew are most of them are locals there's a couple that may be jewish there are a couple of basques a couple of portuguese the thing about criminals is a bit like sort of vladimir putin's
因此，众所周知，我们的许多美国听众对这一点烂熟于心，因为他们在小学里就学过：尼尼亚号、平塔号和圣玛丽亚号。尼尼亚号被称为“女孩号”，但它其实是因为它的主人是一个叫胡安·尼尼亚的人而得名。平塔号，可能以平松兄弟的名字命名，他们是头面人物；而圣玛丽亚号，很明显，它有点像“圣玛丽亚”我猜这就是玛丽的意思。大部分船员都是当地人，有几个人可能是犹太人，有几个巴斯克人，几个葡萄牙人。关于罪犯的事，有点像弗拉基米尔·普京的
recruitment drive isn't it for the wagner group or whatever yeah they are there's probably about four or five of them who've been given permission and brilliantly isn't there there's um there's a guy who can speak um arabic and hebrew yes because they louis torre yeah so they think this is going to be useful when they arrive in china they have this this funny fantasy don't they? There's always been this idea of a man called Presto John, who is out there, who's a Christian king. Is he in Africa? Is he in Arabia? Ethiopia is a very popular place. Right. And they don't know whether maybe the great Khan of Cathay, as they call him, the Chinese emperor, will have some kind of links to Presto John. And they'll be able to do some
瓦格纳集团或其他什么的招募行动，对吧？是的，大概有四五个人被给予了许可。而且非常妙的是，有一个人会说阿拉伯语和希伯来语，是的，因为他们有路易斯·德·托雷斯，对吧？所以他们认为当他们到达中国时这将会很有用。他们有这种滑稽的幻想，不是吗？一直有一种关于一个叫普雷斯特·约翰的人的想法，他在那里，是一个基督教国王。他在非洲吗？他在阿拉伯吗？埃塞俄比亚是一个非常受欢迎的地方。没错。他们不知道契丹伟大可汗（如他们所称的中国皇帝）是否会与普雷斯特·约翰有一些联系。他们将能够做一些
kind of deal to team up and attack Islam from all sides. So maybe having an Arabic and Hebrew interpreter isn't quite as demented as it might seem. I don't imagine he got a lot of interpreting. He got a lot of translating in. No, I don't think he did. But it's interesting, no priest goes, which from the point of view of whether this is about making money or spreading the word suggests that it's probably about making money you'd think they would be able to rustle up a friar or something but they don't i'll tell you the most amazing fact i couldn't believe this when i read it in i can't
某种交易，联合起来从四面八方攻击伊斯兰教。所以，有一个阿拉伯语和希伯来语的翻译可能并不像看起来那么疯狂。我猜他没做成多少翻译工作。他翻译了不少东西。不，我想他没有。但有趣的是，没有牧师同行，从这究竟是关于赚钱还是传播信仰的角度来看，这表明它可能主要是关于赚钱。你本以为他们能设法凑出一个修士什么的，但我告诉你那个最惊人的事实，当我读到它时我简直不敢相信，我不
remember whether where i read it hugh thomas or um fernando cervantes or one of these writers who've written about the spanish conquests that none of these men were paid until 1513. I mean, that's late, isn't it? That's 21 years, Tom. That's worse than the New Statesman. I mean, that's bad. Yeah, that is bad. But they find ways, don't they? I mean, they're hoping to make their own money.
记得我是在哪里读到的了，是休·托马斯还是费尔南多·塞万提斯，或者是这些写过西班牙征服史的作家之一，这些人直到1513年才拿到薪水。我的意思是，这太晚了，对吧？那是21年，汤姆。这比《新政治家》杂志还糟糕。我的意思是，这太糟了。是的，这真的很糟。但他们总能找到出路，不是吗？我的意思是，他们希望自己赚钱。
Yes, I think they are. I think they're hoping to bring back loads of booty and stuff, aren't they? But also, I mean, the key thing to bear in mind is that the reason why the Portuguese and now the Castilians are doing this is because relative to the great empires of the East, the Indians, the Chinese, maybe even who knows the people of Japango, the Japanese, Europeans are poor. They don't actually have stuff that the people in asia want yeah um and so they they kind of take trinkets as gifts but i'm kind of remembered of um fasco tagama in in the episode we did in portugal that he turns up in in india with his trinkets yes that's right and the local king laughs in his face exactly why do we want this junk he's like
是的，我想他们是这样的。我想他们希望带回大量的战利品之类的东西，对吧？但同时，我的意思是需要记住的关键一点是，葡萄牙人和现在卡斯蒂利亚人之所以这样做，是因为相对于东方的大帝国——印度人、中国人，甚至可能还有谁知道呢，日本（Japango）的人民——欧洲人是贫穷的。他们实际上没有什么亚洲人民想要的东西。是的，所以他们拿一些小饰品当作礼物，但我不禁想起法斯科·达·伽马在我们在葡萄牙做的那集节目中，他带着他的小饰品出现在印度，是的，那是对的，当地国王当着他的面嘲笑他。确切地说，为什么我们要这些破烂？他就像
a man who's got loads of stuff from poundland it's only up to trade or something yes no exactly exactly uh they have all these trinkets which they're hoping to exchange for gold and spices that's really what they want they have an obsession with gold and an obsession with spices because that's what you know that that means money in the in the courts of western europe what else are they taking they? We did an episode about drink, didn't we? A wonderful episode about the history of drink with Henry Jeffreys before Christmas. And we were talking about what wine people are drinking these days. So they take a lot of wine with them,
一个有很多廉价小商品店东西的人，这只是为了做贸易什么的。是的，不，完全正确。他们有所有这些小饰品，希望能换取黄金和香料。这真的是他们想要的。他们对黄金有着执念，对香料也有着执念，因为你知道，这意味着西欧宫廷里的金钱。他们还带了什么？我们做过一集关于酒的节目，不是吗？圣诞节前和亨利·杰弗里斯一起录制的一期关于酒的历史的精彩节目。我们当时在谈论人们现在喝什么酒。所以他们带了很多酒，
but the wine they're taking is probably sherry, manzanilla from nearby Sanlúcar. So they've got loads of sherry. They have olive oil oil they have water and all this kind of stuff right from the start i think there is a bit of tension because the problem is that columbus is a foreigner he is genoese he does speak spanish castilian with a kind of unplaceable accent right with yes no one in spain can quite tell where he's come from and he yeah and he downplays his origins he's miss He is consciously mysterious because he doesn't want to be pigeonholed,
但他们带的酒可能是雪利酒，来自附近圣卢卡的曼赞尼亚。所以他们带了大量的雪利酒，有橄榄油、水以及诸如此类的东西。从一开始，我认为就存在一些紧张关系，因为问题在于哥伦布是个外国人。他是热那亚人，他说的卡斯蒂利亚西班牙语带有某种无法归类的口音，对吧？是的，西班牙没有人能准确说出他是哪里来的。而且他淡化了自己的出身。他非常
I think, as a Genoese. But Martin Pinzon, who is the most experienced of the brothers, he really, in some ways, is the guy who has the loyalty. He's probably brought on a lot of the sailors himself. So there is a tension there, and that will become apparent in the rest of the voyage. Anyway, the 3rd of August, 1492, half an hour before sunrise, off they go. And Columbus is a very good mariner. He knows, he's experienced, he's got a plan. The first part is dead easy.
刻意保持神秘，因为他不想被归类为热那亚人。但马丁·平松，作为兄弟中最有经验的一个，在某些方面他确实是那个拥有忠诚度的人。他可能自己招募了许多水手。所以那里存在一种紧张关系，这将在接下来的航行中变得明显。无论如何，1492年8月3日，日出前半小时，他们出发了。哥伦布是一个非常优秀的水手。他懂行，经验丰富，并且有一个计划。第一部分非常容易。
The first part is to the Canary Islands. So that to you know tenerife lanzarote these islands off the coast of africa um very big holiday destinations these days for british and german irish tourists off they go that takes about a week or so it's dead easy you're going kind of with the current with the wind could i could i talk about winds please talk away tom people who've been listening to the show will know that um well both dominic and I are renowned for our knowledge of nautical... Practised mariners. And Dominic, in the previous episode, you devastated me with your knowledge of... Latine rigging.
第一部分是去加那利群岛。也就是特内里费岛、兰萨罗特岛，这些位于非洲海岸外的岛屿，如今是英国、德国和爱尔兰游客的非常热门的度假胜地。他们出发了，这大约花了一周左右的时间，非常容易。你是顺着洋流和风前进的。我能谈谈风吗？请便，汤姆。听过这个节目的听众都会知道，多米尼克和我以我们对航海知识的了解而闻名……熟练的水手。多米尼克，在上一集中，你用你对三角索具的知识震撼了我。
Of Latine rigging. But I was looking up on the winds. Yeah. And what I hadn't properly understood, and I should have done because we did a whole episode on Portuguese exploration. Apparently, it's incredibly important to this. The reason why people had not managed to go out into the Atlantic is because people are terrified about sailing with the wind. So they always want to sail against the wind because then they have the assurance that they can get blown back. Right.
关于三角索具。但我一直在查阅关于风的资料。是的。而我没有完全理解的是——我本该懂的，因为我们做过一整集关于葡萄牙探索的节目。显然，这对这次航行极其重要。人们一直未能闯入大西洋的原因是，人们对顺风航行感到恐惧。所以他们总是想逆风航行，因为那样他们就有把握能够被吹回来。对吧。
Yeah. And what Columbus is doing is he is saying saying we're going to sail with the wind we're going to have you know we're going to let the wind blow us on the assumption that they will then be able to get back that's the act of of either courage or lunacy yeah depending on your perspective oh it's a very frightening thing for some of these sailors you see because they are heading out into the unknown they've signed up for this voyage but the reason that he starts to have problems quite soon after they've set off is because some of them are thinking this guy's a lunatic and we're never going to get back but at first i mean his idea is so they go they go south to the canary islands there they can they can restock they can do any repairs they need
对。而哥伦布在做的是，他说我们要顺风航行，我们要让风吹着我们走，假设他们随后能够返回。这就是充满勇气或疯狂的举动，取决于你的视角。哦，对其中一些水手来说，这是一件非常可怕的事情，因为他们正驶向未知。他们报名参加了这次航行，但他之所以在出发后不久就开始遇到问题，是因为其中一些人认为这家伙是个疯子，我们永远也回不去了。但起初，他的想法是——所以他们向南前往加那利群岛，在那里他们可以补给，可以进行所需的任何维修
after the ships have been at sea for a bit they've you know they've sussed out how the ships are kind of operating and stuff. They're learning the personality of the three ships. Interesting that we mentioned in the first episode just how important the Canary Islands are as a laboratory for everything that's going to follow in the Americas. So the Canary Islands, it had taken a long time. It had taken decades for the Spanish to subdue the indigenous people.
在船只在海上航行了一段时间之后，他们已经摸清了船只的运作方式等等。他们正在了解这三艘我们在第一集中提到过的船只的个性。加那利群岛作为美洲一切后续事物的实验室有多么重要，这很有趣。加那利群岛，这花了很长时间。西班牙人花了数十年时间才征服土著居民。
They had done it by a mixture of state enterprise and private enterprise. They had then set up sugar plantations and sugar mills, and they had brought in a labor force from Africa of black slaves. So all of these things anticipate what is to follow in the Americas. But Dominic, the fact that it had taken so long because the indigenous peoples didn't want to be annexed and conquered, that's an important aspect, isn't it, for Columbus? Because he knows that Ferdinand and Isabella back in Spain will not want to get sucked into campaigns like that. No. So there's an absolute premium on Columbus, should he discover indigenous peoples in these lands, to emphasize that these are very tractable, peaceable people. Yes. So if Columbus had gone to Ferdinand and Isabella and he had said, listen, I've got this great plan. We're going to go off to this completely unknown continent where there are people living already.
他们通过国家企业和私人企业的结合做到了这一点。然后他们建立起了甘蔗种植园和糖厂，并从非洲引入了黑奴劳动力。所以所有这些事情都预示着美洲将要发生的事情。但是多米尼克，由于土著人民不想被兼并和征服，这花费了这么长时间，对哥伦布来说这是一个重要的方面，不是吗？因为他知道西班牙的费迪南德和伊莎贝拉不会想被卷入这样的战役中。是的。因此，对哥伦布来说，如果他在这些土地上发现土著人民，绝对至关重要的一点是，要强调这些是非常温顺、爱好和平的人。是的。所以，如果哥伦布去找费迪南德和伊莎贝拉，对他们说，听着，我有一个伟大的计划。我们要去一个已经有人居住的完全未知的大陆。
We'll probably have to fight our way in. We'll try to convert some of the people, but lots of them will actually end up enslaving and treating them as forced labor. We will set up towns. We will have colonies. We will all squabble among ourselves and fall out about who is running them.
我们可能不得不一路打过去。我们会试图让一些人皈依，但实际上他们中的许多人最终会被我们奴役并当作劳动力对待。我们将建立城镇。我们将拥有殖民地。我们都会在谁来管理它们的问题上争吵不休并闹翻。
Then obviously Ferdinand and Isabella would never have given him a penny for their voyage or any permission at all. Because one of the things that was really on their minds was that in the Reconquista, so in their great drive to reconquer Granada and the Muslim areas of Spain, there had always been this slight tension then, actually, between the knights and the crown. So they were all about, Ferdinand in particular it was all about asserting the power of the crown, making the crown more powerful, strengthening its bureaucracy, not allowing these basically armed entrepreneurs to kind of completely go off and carve out their own little realms. So if they'd had any suspicion that Columbus was going to do that, or if they'd
那么很显然，费迪南德和伊莎贝拉绝不会为他们的航行出一分钱，也不会给予任何许可。因为真正让他们烦心的事情之一是，在收复失地运动中，也就是他们收复格拉纳达和西班牙穆斯林地区的伟大征程中，骑士与王室之间其实一直存在着这种微小的紧张关系。所以他们全神贯注于——尤其是费迪南德——确立王室的权力，使王室更加强大，加强其官僚机构，不允许这些基本上武装起来的创业者完全跑出去开辟他们自己的小王国。因此，如果他们有任何怀疑认为哥伦布会那样做，或者如果他们
had any sense that this was going to be a really expensive military commitment, they would never have done it in a million years. I mean, what interests them are the spices and the trade with the East. Canary Islands Mark II is not really what they want at all. Anyway, we've sort of gone a bit off piste. Listen, they're at the Canary Islands. They're there for a couple of weeks. They're kind of faffing around with their sails. They repair their rigging. They take on new supplies and stuff. Then they have to wait for the winds. You know, I know you love the winds, Tom.
觉得这将是一项非常昂贵的军事承诺，他们绝不会在一百万年里答应这件事。我的意思是，吸引他们的是香料和与东方的贸易。加那利群岛二号并不是他们真正想要的。不管怎样，我们有点偏离正题了。听着，他们在加那利群岛。他们在那里呆了几个星期。他们一直在鼓捣他们的风帆。他们修理索具。他们补充了新的物资等等。然后他们必须等待风向。我知道你喜欢风，汤姆。
They have to wait for the winds to be right, to catch the full wind. And on the morning of the 6th of September, they go to church. Columbus raises sail. And out they go from La Gomera, one of the Canary Islands. So off they go, off into the unknown. This is not a barrel of laughs by any means. So they are living on wine, water, ship's biscuits, which is kind of very hard sort of bread. They've got a little bit of fish. They've got a little bit of salted pork. When they're not working on the ship, they're spending their time gambling. They might be reading. So some of them might have books with them.
他们必须等待风向合适，借足风力。在9月6日的早晨，他们去教堂做礼拜。哥伦布起航。他们从加那利群岛之一的拉戈梅拉岛出发了。于是他们出发了，驶向未知的世界。这绝不是一件开心的事。所以他们靠酒、水、舰艇饼干维生，那是一种非常硬的面包。他们有一点点鱼。他们有一点点盐猪肉。当他们不在船上工作时，他们就把时间花在赌博上。他们可能会读书。所以他们中的一些人可能会随身带书。
Columbus is probably looking at all his charts. And doesn't he have kind of various instruments that he doesn't actually know how to use? He's kind of showing off about that. He does. He's got hourglasses. The hourglasses don't last very long. They last about 15 minutes or some of them a half an hour. He's got hourglasses. The hourglasses don't last very long. They last about 15 minutes or some of them a half an hour. He's got a compass.
哥伦布可能在查看他所有的海图。他是不是还有各种他其实不会用的仪器？他有点在显摆这个。他确实有。他有沙漏。沙漏持续时间不长。它们大约持续15分钟，有些持续半小时。他有沙漏。沙漏持续时间不长。它们大约持续15分钟，有些持续半小时。他有一个罗盘。
It's kind of like he's got an iPhone, but he doesn't know how to use any of the apps. A little bit. A little bit. He's got a compass. He's got an astrolabe. So the astrolabes, the Portuguese have got them from the Arabs. Explain how the astrolabe works, Dominic. So an astrolabe has degrees on it, Tom, and you can calculate the stars, your position.
这有点像他有一个iPhone，但他不知道怎么用里面的任何应用程序。有点像。有点像。他有一个罗盘。他有一个星盘。星盘是葡萄牙人从阿拉伯人那里得到的。多米尼克，解释一下星盘是如何工作的。所以，星盘上有度数，汤姆，你可以计算星星，也就是你的位置。
You can triangulate your position from the stars by using your astrolabe. Does that explain to you? Brilliant. So the astrolabe is on the Portuguese flag. Yeah. So astrolabes are absolutely central to the Age of Discovery. He also probably has a map.
你可以通过使用星盘从星星中三角定位你的位置。这能向你解释清楚吗？太棒了。所以星盘在葡萄牙国旗上。是的。因此，星盘对于大航海时代绝对至关重要。他可能还带了一张地图。
No one is quite sure what map he has. Maybe it was one given to him by this guy Toscanelli, who we mentioned in the previous episode, one of the Florentine thinker who was one of the people who had inspired his idea of crossing the Atlantic. There's a globe, isn't there, that's made in 1492, I think in Nuremberg. Yes. And it's the oldest surviving globe and it shows the coast of Europe and Africa. Yeah. And then it's just a huge, great blank expanse where America is. This is what his sailors are thinking.
没有人确切知道他带的是什么地图。也许是我们在上一集中提到的那个佛罗伦萨思想家托斯卡内利送给他的地图，他是启发了哥伦布横渡大西洋想法的人之一。有一个地球仪，对吧，制作于1492年，我记得是在纽伦堡。是的。它是现存最古老的地球仪，它展示了欧洲和非洲的海岸。是的。然后就是美洲所在的一片巨大无比的空白。这就是他的水手们所想的。
They're sailing into the void. Of course. And they're sailing in. I mean, to be a sailor on these ships is pretty grim. You know, you're sleeping outside, probably on sacks. The toilet is set up on a grating overlooking the sea. When your clothes get dirty, you can't wash and change your clothes, so you're in your dirty clothes the whole time.
他们正在驶向虚无。当然。他们正在驶入。我的意思是，这些船上的水手生活相当悲惨。你知道，你睡在外面，可能睡在麻袋上。厕所搭在一个俯瞰大海的格栅上。当你的衣服变脏时，你不能洗衣服和换衣服，所以你一直穿着脏衣服。
If you're in a storm, it's just utterly miserable. You're just bailing out water. Terrible toilet facilities. Terrible toilets. Everything is awful. So Columbus pulls his trick, doesn't he, where he keeps an actual log in which he talks up how many days they've been and another one for public consumption where he cuts down on the days.
如果你遇到风暴，那简直是痛苦不堪。你只能不停地舀水。糟糕的厕所设施。糟糕的厕所。一切都很糟糕。所以哥伦布耍了个花招，对吧？他保留了一份实际的航海日志，上面记录了他们航行了多少天，而另一份供大众公开查阅的日志则缩短了天数。
This is the most incredible thing. So in the first episode, we presented this image of him as this sort of eccentric visionary. The extraordinary thing is, even though he's very good at sailing and navigating and so on, pretty much from the beginning, from about the 10th of September onwards, he is lying to his crew about where they are. Because he is obsessed with this idea. The Atlantic is much smaller than it is. And he has two logs, one in which one of the others see where he's deliberately underestimating how far they've gone. So in other words, that'll make it easy for them to get back. And then the other, which is the sort of true one, he's also kind of lying to himself because he is making observations all the time with his compasses and all this stuff about where the pole star is and where they are.
这真是最不可思议的事情。所以在第一集里，我们把他塑造成了一种古怪的梦想家形象。最离奇的是，尽管他非常擅长航海和导航等等，但几乎从一开始，大约从9月10日左右起，他就一直在向船员隐瞒他们所在的位置。因为他痴迷于这个想法。大西洋比实际要小得多。他有两本日志，其中一本其他人可以看到，他故意低估了他们已经航行的距离。换句话说，这会让他们觉得返程很容易。然后另一本，也就是所谓真实的日志，他其实也在某种程度上自欺欺人，因为他一直在用罗盘以及关于北极星位置和他们所在位置的各种工具进行观测。
And it's not working. It doesn't fit his chart. But there is one positive, which is that on the 22nd of September, they get an adverse wind. So they could be blown back. And so that means they can be blown back. So that's a cause for kind of cheering them up. But against that, there's no land. No, exactly.
但这没用。这与他的海图不符。但有一个积极的因素，那就是在9月22日，他们遇到了逆风。所以他们可能会被吹回去。这意味着他们可以被吹回去。所以这成了一个让他们振作起来的理由。但与之相对的是，依然没有陆地。不，确实如此。
And just two days later. So you said that was on the 22nd, which it was. On the 24th, there's already trouble on the ship. Some of the sailors are saying, this is mad. So they've been gone now for a month and a half. And they are saying, one of them says, it was great madness and self-inflicted homicide to risk their lives in order to follow the folly of a foreigner who was ready to die to make himself a grand seigneur. So they know why Columbus is doing this, because it's making himself a grand seigneur. And they don't like the thought that they are
仅仅两天后。所以你刚才说那是22号，确实如此。到了24号，船上已经出现麻烦了。一些水手说，这太疯狂了。他们已经离开了一个半月。他们中的一个人说，为了追随一个准备死去以让自己成为大老爷的外国人的愚蠢行为而冒着生命危险，这是极大的疯狂和自杀行为。所以他们知道哥伦布为什么要这么做，因为这能让他成为一个大老爷。他们不喜欢这种想法，那就是他们
just collateral damage. But against that, I mean, it reminds you, I mean, because we're so accustomed to the idea that America exists and that Columbus discovers it, that you have to think yourself back into his shoes and the shoes of all his crewmen to appreciate the incredible courage it must have taken. Yeah. I mean, no matter what else you say about Columbus. Oh yeah. He's incredibly brave.
只是无辜的牺牲品。但话又说回来，我的意思是，这提醒了我们——因为我们太习惯于美洲的存在以及哥伦布发现美洲这一概念，所以你必须设身处地为他着想，并站在他所有船员的立场上，才能体会到当时肯定需要多么不可思议的勇气。是的。我的意思是，无论你对哥伦布有何其他评价。哦，是的。他极其勇敢。
He had balls. Yes, he did. He has enormous physical, whatever. I mean, he doesn't always behave well and we will undoubtedly be spending a lot of time talking about that in future episodes. But he does have enormous physical and kind of mental courage, psychological courage. And he enters into a kind of battle of wills with Martin Pinzon, doesn't he? Yes. Who is not happy.
他很有种。是的，他确实如此。他有着巨大的体能，无论如何。我的意思是，他并不总是表现得很好，毫无疑问，我们将在以后的节目中花很多时间讨论这一点。但他确实拥有巨大的体力和某种精神勇气、心理勇气。他与马丁·平松展开了一场意志较量，不是吗？是的。他对现状很不满。
Who says to him, the sailors don't like this. I don't like it. They go on for another two weeks. They see nothing. Columbus says to them at one point, I'm like Moses leading you through the wilderness. Yeah, that's not reassuring, is it? They don't find that reassuring at all. On the 5th of October, Martin Pynthon says, I think you should change course. I think you should head southwest to try and find Japan. We're heading nowhere. Now, they have a big quarrel, and Columbus eventually agrees to do this.
他对他说，水手们不喜欢这样。我也不喜欢。他们又航行了两周。什么也没看到。哥伦布在某个时刻对他们说，我就像带领你们穿过荒野的摩西。是的，这可一点也不让人安心，对吧？他们一点也不觉得这让人安心。10月5日，马丁·平松说，我认为你应该改变航向。我认为你应该向西南方驶去，试着寻找日本。我们现在漫无目的。现在，他们大吵了一架，哥伦布最终同意这样做。
The fascinating thing, I think it's Hugh Thomas who mentions this in Rivers of Gold. If Columbus had not agreed and they'd kept going, they would have landed on Florida. Yeah, imagine that. The world might look different in all kinds of ways. Might have been eaten by an alligator. By an alligator. Maybe. Maybe.
最迷人的是，我想是休·托马斯在《黄金之河》中提到了这一点：如果哥伦布没有同意而继续前行，他们就会在佛罗里达登陆。是的，想象一下。世界可能会在各种方面看起来完全不同。可能会被短吻鳄吃掉。被短吻鳄。也许吧。也许。
They'd have discovered Disney World. Yeah. Anyway, they- So they turn left, as I believe sailors describe it. They turn left, exactly. That's your nautical terminology, Tom. They do turn left. Continued discontent from the sailors.
他们就会发现迪士尼乐园了。是的。无论如何，他们——所以他们向左转，我想水手们是这么形容的。他们向左转，一点没错。那是你的航海术语，汤姆。他们的确向左转了。水手们的不满情绪仍在继续。
So on the 6th of October, the Pinzon brothers basically say to Columbus, you've got three days. If we don't discover land in three days, we are turning back and going home. And then they see birds, don't they? Yes. The next day, Columbus sees birds on the 7th. And then on the 10th, still discontent among the men. And Columbus says, I will give a coat of silk to the man who first sees land.
因此，在10月6日，平松兄弟基本上对哥伦布说，你只有三天时间。如果我们三天内没有发现陆地，我们就掉头回家。然后他们看到了鸟，对吧？是的。第二天，也就是7号，哥伦布看到了鸟。然后在10号，船员中仍然存在不满情绪。哥伦布说，谁第一个看到陆地，我就奖赏他一件丝绸外衣。
And apparently when he says this, it's just a dead silence on the ship. It's just not what I want. Because none of them have any need. I mean, they sort of think, well, if I'm going to drown, a silk coat will avail me nothing. Well, also, their clothes are actually filthy, as you said, because they've been wearing them for about three months. Exactly.
显然，当他说出这话时，船上一片死寂。这根本不是大家想要的。因为他们根本不需要。我的意思是，他们心里想，好吧，如果我要淹死了，一件丝绸外衣对我也毫无用处。嗯，而且，他们的衣服其实很脏，正如你所说，因为他们已经穿了大约三个月了。没错。
Yes. filthy as you said because they've been yeah wearing them for about three months exactly yes but at that same day the 10th uh both columbus and martin they they see birds and martin pinthorn says birds do not fly like that with no reason meaning if there's birds yeah then there must be land and um columbus, he says, I think I might see land. He describes it as, where is it? Like the light of a wax candle moving up and down. And some of the sailors clearly think, well, he's just, he's bonkers. You know, he's just saying this. Or is there an alternative explanation? Because the big reveal, 2 a.m. Friday, the 12th of October, land is spotted.
是的。正如你所说很脏，因为他们已经——是的——穿了大约三个月了，确实如此，是的。但在同一天，即10日，呃，哥伦布和马丁都看到了鸟，马丁·平松说鸟类飞行绝不会无缘无故地那样，意思如果有鸟，是的，那肯定有陆地，而且，呃，哥伦布说，我想我可能看到陆地了。他将其描述为，在哪里？就像一根蜡烛的火焰在上下移动。有些水手显然认为，好吧，他只是疯了。你知道，他只是在胡说八道。还是说有另一种解释？因为最大的高潮来了，周五凌晨2点，即10月12日，发现了陆地。
And the guy who's up in the crow's nest, he's the guy who can claim the silk coat. But isn't there a case for saying that actually it's Columbus rewriting it? Because he wants to be the first to see it. Yeah, of course. Of course. I don't think he saw it. I think the man in the crow's nest, as you say, it's a full moon that night as well.
那个在瞭望台上的人，他就是那个可以宣称获得丝绸外衣的人。但难道没有理由认为这实际上是哥伦布在事后重写日志吗？因为他想成为第一个看到它的人。是的，当然。当然。我不认为是他看到的。正如你所说，是瞭望台上的那个人，那天晚上也是满月。
So he's a man from Seville called Juan Rodriguez Bermejo, and he says he sees a white stretch of land, and they fire a little gun, a little cannon called a lombard, and everybody is kind of shouting and cheering and praising God. And it is an incredible moment. Amazing. I mean, they have gone all that way on Columbus's mad whim. They, I mean, we said they don't know that America is out there.
所以他是一个来自塞维利亚的家伙，名叫胡安·罗德里格斯·贝尔梅霍，他说他看到了一片白色的陆地，然后他们鸣放了一门小火炮，也就是伦巴德炮，每个人都在大喊大叫、欢呼雀跃并赞美上帝。这真是一个不可思议的时刻。太棒了。我的意思是，他们凭着哥伦布疯狂的一时冲动走了那么远。他们，我的意思是，我们说过他们并不知道美洲就在那里。
I mean, there's no mention of America. They think they are going to Japan. Yes. And then, or possibly they've missed Japan and they're now going to China. This is all part of the, I mean, you know, the difficulty of deciding what it is that they found is that they have this weird Asian map in their head. Yeah. But I do think it's so indicative of Columbus's character that he has to try and appropriate
我的意思是，根本没有提到美洲。他们以为自己要去日本。是的。然后，或者可能他们错过了日本，现在正前往中国。这都是其中的一部分，我的意思是，你知道，要判定他们究竟发现了什么之所以困难，是因为他们脑海中有一张奇怪的亚洲地图。是的。但我确实认为这非常能体现哥伦布的性格，他必须要试图将
the moment for himself. Yes. It's frustrating with Columbus, isn't it? Because so little is written about the first 40 years. There's so little documentary evidence of the first 40 years of his life. And then he behaves in such a sort of disputatious and prickly way that everything that is subsequently written about him paints him in the worst possible light. But you do get these glimpses of this guy. But very human. I mean, he's a very human figure. He's insecure, isn't he? You know, he's quite Nixonian, Tom. Yes, I suppose.
这个时刻占为己有。是的。对哥伦布感到很无奈，对吧？因为关于他前40年的记载实在太少了。关于他生命前40年的文献证据少之又少。然后他又表现得如此好辩和敏感，以至于后来关于他的一切书写都把他描绘成最糟糕的形象。但你确实能从这些吉光片羽中看到这个人。不过非常人性化。我的意思是，他是一个非常人性化的形象。他很不安全感，对吧？你知道，他挺像尼克松的，汤姆。是的，我想是的。
I mean, he's a man of clearly titanic achievement and gifts, but who in a way is also his own worst enemy. Anyway, we shouldn't dwell on this. This is a moment of great triumph. Yeah. I mean, an astonishing moment, a pivotal moment in Columbus's life and in the history of Europe and indeed of the entire world so let's take a break and when we come back we will we'll see what what it is that Columbus has run into is it Japan is it China or is it something completely else I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
我的意思是，他显然是一个拥有泰坦般的成就和天赋的人，但在某种程度上，他也是他自己最大的敌人。不管怎样，我们不应纠结于此。这是一个伟大的胜利时刻。是的。我的意思是，这是一个惊人的时刻，是哥伦布生命中、欧洲历史乃至整个世界历史上至关重要的时刻，所以让我们休息一下，当我们回来时，我们将看看哥伦布究竟遇到了什么——是日本？是中国？还是完全其他的东西？我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》，这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八秀圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com at two o'clock in the morning the land was discovered at two leagues distance they took in sail and remained under the square sail lying to till day which was friday when they found themselves near a small island one of the lukeos called it in the indian language guanahani so that's col's Columbus's journal describing the historic, historic day, the discovery of, well, what, Dominic, what does he think he's found? Well, that phrase that you used there, actually, that he used, called in the Indian language,
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外剧集并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestofthenertainment.com，也就是therestofthenertainment.com。凌晨两点，在距离两里地的地方发现了陆地。他们收起船帆，在方形帆下待命，漂航直到天亮，那是星期五，当时他们发现自己靠近卢卡亚群岛中的一个小岛，印第安语称之为瓜纳哈尼。这就是哥伦布的航海日志，描述了那个具有历史意义的日子，发现……嗯，什么呢，多米尼克，他认为自己发现了什么？好吧，你刚才用的那个词，实际上就是他用的，印第安语称之为
Guanahani. So right from the beginning, Columbus is describing the people as Indians and using the phrase, the Indian language. It's a testament to the vagueness of his project in some ways. Is it China? Is it Japan? Is it India? He doesn't know at this stage. People still disagree about exactly where it was Columbus landed. It's probably a place called Watling Island in the Bahamas. Columbus calls it San Salvador, the Holy Savior. Local people that he meets who will come to in a second, they tell him it's somewhere that sounds a bit like Guanahani. Does he know where it is? I'm not sure he does. I think he thinks it's an island off the coast of Japan or China. He knows it's not the mainland. But he'd immediately have found out that the Hebrew and Arabic interpreter- Useless.
瓜纳哈尼。所以从一开始，哥伦布就把当地人描述为印第安人，并使用了“印第安语”这个词。这在某种程度上证明了他的计划的模糊性。这是中国？是日本？还是印度？他在这个阶段并不清楚。人们对哥伦布登陆的具体地点仍然存在争议。那很可能是巴哈马群岛的一个叫做沃特林岛的地方。哥伦布将其命名为圣萨尔瓦多，意为“神圣的救世主”。他遇到的当地人——我们稍后会提到——告诉他，这个地方听起来有点像瓜纳哈尼。他知道这是哪里吗？我不太确定他知道。我想他认为这是日本或中国海岸附近的一个岛屿。他知道这不是大陆。但他很快就会发现，希伯来语和阿拉伯语翻译——毫无用处。
No good. Yeah. They don't speak Hebrew. I mean, the interesting thing is that straight away, Columbus raises the, he takes possession of it in the name of Spain, and he raises the flag of Ferdinand and Isabella, which is this green cross with an F for Ferdinand, a Y for Isabella on a white background. And as historians have said, this again again, is a strange thing to do because if he thinks this belongs to the emperor of Japan or the emperor of China...
没用。是的。他们不会说希伯来语。我的意思是，有趣的是，哥伦布立刻提出了这一点，他以西班牙的名义占领了它，并升起了斐迪南和伊莎贝拉的旗帜，这是一个绿色的十字架，背景是白色的，上面有代表斐迪南的“F”和代表伊莎贝拉的“Y”。正如历史学家所说，这再次是一种奇怪的做法，如果他认为这属于日本皇帝或中国皇帝的话……
Yeah, a provocation. Yeah, it's reckless. It is reckless. But perhaps he thinks, yes, it's a sort of desert island off the coast of Asia somewhere. He sees locals pretty much straight away, and he calls them Indians from the very beginning. And these locals are naked, right?
是的，一种挑衅。是的，这很鲁莽。这确实很鲁莽。但也许他想，是的，这只是亚洲海岸附近的一个荒岛。他几乎立刻就看到了当地人，从一开始就称他们为印第安人。而这些当地人是一丝不挂的，对吧？
Yes. And there's immediately a question there, I guess, which again will hang over decades, centuries of European engagement with indigenous peoples. Is this nakedness a symbol of innocence? So like Adam and Eve in the Garden of Eden, or is it a symbol of savagery and backwardness? And that kind of innocent or savage, it's the polarity that will shadow all Columbus's voyages. And I think Columbus changes his mind based on the circumstances. So I don't think he has any consistency. So when they are think he has any consistency. So when they are nice to him and when he's feeling good and things are going well,
是的。我想这里立刻产生了一个问题，这个问题也将长期笼罩在欧洲与原住民接触的几十年乃至几个世纪中。这种赤裸是纯洁的象征吗？就像伊甸园里的亚当和夏娃一样，还是野蛮和落后的象征？这种纯洁与野蛮的对立，将伴随哥伦布所有的航行。我认为哥伦布会根据情况改变主意。所以我觉得他没有什么一贯性。因此，当他们对他是好的，当他感觉良好并且事情进展顺利时，
he says, oh, they're lovely, lovely people. But he needs them to be lovely, doesn't he? Because otherwise it'll screw up all his pitch that he's made to Ferdinand and Isabella. Exactly, exactly. And at first, actually, they are very, I mean, by and large, pretty friendly, pretty welcoming. So they are amazed by the Europeans. They, as you said, they have no clothes. Some of them have painted their bodies. They have wooden spears.
他说，哦，他们是可爱的人，可爱的人。但他需要他们是可爱的，对吧？否则就会搞砸他向斐迪南和伊莎贝拉推销的整套说辞。确实如此，确实如此。起码一开始，他们实际上非常——总的来说，相当友好，相当热情。所以他们对欧洲人感到惊奇。正如你所说，他们没有穿衣服。他们中的一些人彩绘了身体。他们拿着木制长矛。
They have canoes. He's very interested from the beginning. Some of them have golden ornaments. So golden piercings. Yeah. And gold is what they've come for. And they say to him, or they communicate by sign language, not through the Arabic and Hebrew speaking interpreter,
他们有独木舟。他从一开始就很感兴趣。他们中的一些人有黄金饰品。比如黄金穿孔。是的。而黄金正是他们此行的目的。他们对他说，或者通过手势交流——而不是通过会说阿拉伯语和希伯来语的翻译——
to say there are kings maybe to the south who have lots of gold. And of course at that, his ears prick up. And this is a trick that people will do throughout the story of Spanish colonization. It is to say, oh, there's people just over the hill just over the hill loads of gold you should you should go and see them now straight away columbus does something that some listeners will have been waiting for from the very beginning of this story which is he captures and enslaves people so he takes them as interpreters or such is his claim.
说可能在南方有国王拥有大量的黄金。当然，听到这话，他的耳朵立刻竖起来了。这也是人们在西班牙殖民统治的整个历史中会使用的一个把戏，那就是说，哦，就在山那边，就在山那边，有海量的黄金，你们应该马上去看看。现在，马上，哥伦布做了一件有些听众从这个故事一开始就一直在等待的事情，那就是他捕捉并奴役了当地人——所以他把他们当作翻译，或者他以此为借口。
So in the next couple of weeks, he starts to seize indigenous people. He has one who actually remains with him who he calls Diego Columbus, who stays with him for the next two years. That duality that you talked about, are they innocent? Are they children in the Garden of Eden? Or are they kind of bestial, primitive people whom we can treat as we like? I think that is there. That tension is there from the beginning. So he says to, at first he says to Ferdinand and Isabella, they're very timid, they are artless, they will make good subjects. So he's already
所以在接下来的几周里，他开始抓捕原住民。他留下了一个人陪着他，他叫他迭戈·哥伦布，这个人陪伴了他两年。你刚才提到的那种二元性：他们是无辜的吗？他们是伊甸园里的孩子吗？还是我们可以随意对待的某种野蛮、原始的人？我认为这种矛盾是存在的。这种紧张关系从一开始就存在。所以他最初对斐迪南和伊莎贝拉说，他们非常胆小，他们没有心机，会成为优秀的臣民。所以他已经
thinking that way. But the question of slavery is hanging there from the very beginning, because Spain is a society that already has 100,000 slaves in Spain. So slavery is not a novelty. It is already part of the mental furniture of these islands, they're immediately thinking, well, will they make good slaves? Can we send them back home? Is this where we're going to make our money, basically? But this island that he's found is small. Yeah, tiny, tiny. And he stops at others as well. And so it's clearly not Japan. It's clearly not China.
抱有这种想法。但关于奴隶制的问题从一开始就悬而未决，因为西班牙本土本身就已经有十万名奴隶了。所以奴隶制并不是什么新鲜事。这已经是这些岛民固有观念的一部分了，他们马上就在想，这些人能当好奴隶吗？我们能把他们送回老家吗？基本上这就是我们赚钱的门路吗？但他发现的这个岛很小。对，非常非常小。他也经停了其他岛屿。所以这显然不是日本。这显然不是中国。
So he sails on. Yes. And he bumps into a land that, according to the locals, is Colba. They call it Colba, which becomes Cuba. And Columbus presumably is very keen that Cuba actually be China. He changes his mind about whether it could be Japan or China. But I think at first, he thinks it's going to be Japan. And then he gets there and he says, actually, it's probably China. And he sends off, in fact, he's got letters for the great Khan of China. So you can imagine what people, he says, you know, let's team up and go and attack.
于是他继续起航。是的。然后他撞上了一片土地，当地人说那里叫科尔巴（Colba）。他们管它叫科尔巴，后来就成了古巴。哥伦布大概非常渴望古巴实际上就是中国。他改变了关于这究竟是日本还是中国的看法。但我想起初他觉得这会是日本。接着他到了那里，然后他说，其实，这可能中国。于是他派出了使团，实际上，他身上带着给中国大汗的信件。所以你可以想象人们的想法，他说，你知道的，让我们联合起来去进攻。
Let's attack the Turks and take Jerusalem. Yeah, take out Mecca. The reaction of these people hearing this is they're dumbfounded i think it's fair to say so he calls the island juana after um joanna uh of castile and then he eventually ends up calling it fernandina after ferdinand he's really struck by how beautiful cuba is uh he interacts with the people um he sends an embassy out so as you said he does end up thinking this is probably cafe it's probably china he sends um an embassy with i want i mean one of the accounts says with a with a interpreter who speaks chaldean um which i imagine is unlikely yeah
去进攻土耳其人并夺取耶路撒冷。对，拿下麦加。这些听到这话的人的反应是目瞪口呆，我觉得这么说很公平，所以他把这个岛命名为胡安娜（Juana），以纪念卡斯蒂利亚的……嗯……乔安娜（Joanna）；然后他最终又把它命名为费尔南迪纳（Fernandina），以斐迪南（Ferdinand）命名。古巴的美丽给他留下了深刻的印象，嗯，他与当地人进行交流，嗯，他派出了一个使团——正如你所说，他最终确实认为这可能是契丹（Cathay），这可能是中国——他派出了一个使团，其中——我的意思是，其中一份记载说——带着一个会说迦勒底语的翻译，嗯，我觉得这不太可能，对。
improbable yeah but it's also very improbable the people on cuba speak chaldean anyway so they go out and they actually find a little town, a sort of massive big village of wooden huts. And these people are the Tainos. So these are the indigenous people of the Caribbean. And they are, I suppose, if it's not a sort of cancelable term, more advanced, more sophisticated culture than the people on Watling Island. They're smoking, right?
不大可能，对吧。不过古巴人会说迦勒底语的可能性也非常小。不管怎样，他们出发了，并且真的找到了一个小镇，一个由木屋组成的大型村落。这些人就是泰诺人（Tainos）。所以这些就是加勒比地区的土耳其（原住民）。而且，如果这不是一个容易引起取消文化的词的话，我想他们的文化比沃特灵岛（Watling Island）的人们更先进、更成熟。他们在抽烟，对吧？
Yeah, they have tobacco. They're all kind of hanging out in that village, puffing away. Having a smoke. Having a smoke. They're sitting on chairs. They have wooden chairs. They have furniture. They're sitting having a smoke.
是的，他们有烟草。他们都聚在那个村子里吞云吐雾。抽着烟。抽着烟。他们坐在椅子上。他们有木椅。他们有家具。他们坐在那里抽烟。
So Columbus sort of thinks to himself, well, these people are very promising. He's very sort of excited by this. But clearly, some of the people that he is with that have come with him are already thinking, this is not what we signed up for. This is not China and Japan. So Martin Pinton, who we mentioned in the first half, on the 20th of November, he's had enough and he sails off in the Pinta with some of the crew to have a look for himself because he clearly thinks at this stage this is this is not what we've bargained for and columbus has led us on a wild goose chase columbus then says well okay let's all set off and see if we can find some more china or whatever and they end up on hispaniola so that's the island that's current that's now divided between haiti and the dominican republic um the second biggest island in the caribbean he calls it la espanola because it looks a little bit the vegetation and the the trees and stuff the flora and fauna are a little bit more like europe he thinks this is japan so he thought cuba was china and he thinks this is japan
所以哥伦布心里想，这些人很有前途。他对此感到非常兴奋。但很显然，与他同行的、和他一起来的一些人已经在想了：这不是我们当初签约要干的事。这不是中国和日本。所以我们在前半部分提到过的马丁·平松（Martin Pinzon），在11月20日，他已经受够了，他带着部分船员乘平塔号（Pinta）扬帆起航，想自己去寻找一番，因为他显然觉得在这个阶段，这根本不是我们讨价还价买卖的一部分，哥伦布带我们进行了一场毫无结果的瞎胡闹。于是哥伦布说，好吧，那我们大家一起出发，看看能不能找到更多中国之类的地方。最后他们来到了伊斯帕尼奥拉岛（Hispaniola）——也就是现在被海地和多米尼加共和国瓜分的那个岛，加勒比海第二大岛。他把它叫做拉伊斯帕尼奥拉（La Espanola），因为这里的植被、树木之类的动植物看起来有点更像欧洲。他以为这是日本。所以他之前以为古巴是中国，而他觉得这里是日本。
he's very interested because the people on Hispaniola are more sophisticated. Their civilization is more sophisticated still than their neighbors on Cuba. So they have things that they've probably got from the Maya in Yucatan. They have things like more complicated stonework. They have ball courts for playing the kind of Maya ball game. They have more big villages like little towns. They have hammocks and canoes and tobacco and all of these things.
他非常感兴趣，因为伊斯帕尼奥拉岛的人更加成熟。他们的文明比他们在古巴的邻居还要更加成熟。所以他们拥有可能从尤卡坦（Yucatan）的玛雅人那里得到的东西。他们拥有更复杂的石雕之类东西。他们有用来玩玛雅球类游戏的球场。他们有更多像小镇一样的大村庄。他们有吊床、独木舟、烟草以及所有这些东西。
Pineapple. Pineapples, exactly. And they also have, there are traces, what appear to be traces of gold. And this is going to become a real obsession for Columbus. So Columbus is very interested by the gold and he thinks that their native people are great. So he writes to interested by the gold and he thinks that the native people are great. So he writes to Ferdinand and Isabella, he says, they are such an affectionate and
菠萝。菠萝，没错。而且他们还有，有痕迹，看起来像是黄金的痕迹。这将成为哥伦布真正的痴迷所在。所以哥伦布对黄金非常感兴趣，他认为那里的本地人棒极了。于是他写信给……对黄金非常感兴趣，他认为本地人棒极了。所以他写信给
generous people, so tractable. I assure your highnesses, there are no better people or land in all the world. This is classic Columbus, the hyperbole, the overselling of everything. And he's claiming to have seen Chinese ships, isn't he? And he's prone to exaggeration when he needs to. Definitely. Which means that everything we know about these voyages has to be taken with a slight pinch of salt. So for example, he says, they have given me really nice golden ornaments and masks and things. He also says, they have told me about some terrible neighbours of theirs called the Caribs, who are cannibals well the word
斐迪南和伊莎贝拉，他说，他们是如此深情和慷慨的人，如此温顺。我向二位陛下保证，天下再没有比这更好的人民或土地了。这就是典型的哥伦布风格，夸大其词，对一切都大肆吹嘘。而且他声称自己见过中国船只，不是吗？而且他在需要的时候往往会夸大其词。绝对是的。这意味着我们对这些航行的所有了解都必须大打折扣（持保留态度）。比如，他说：他们给了我非常漂亮的黄金饰品、面具之类东西。他还说：他们跟我提起过他们的一些可怕邻居，叫做加勒比人（Caribs），他们是食人族。嗯，这个词
cannibal comes from carib right it does indeed it does indeed so right away in these first encounters you have that duality that runs right through european encounters with indigenous peoples not just in the americas actually but across the world which is on the one hand the noble savage the innocent naked friendly you know sort of characters that people meet. And on the other, the idea of, as it were, the savage savage. They'll eat you. We don't even really know whether the Caribs would have, you know, I mean, they might have done. I mean, the puzzle over that, I mean, it's very tempting to say that he's just made this up and that it's a projection of European dark fantasies and things like that.
“食人族”（cannibal）来自“加勒比人”（carib），对吧？确实如此，确实如此。所以从这些初次接触中，你立刻就看到了那种贯穿欧洲人与原住民接触始终的二元性，不仅在美洲，实际上在全世界都是如此：一方面是高贵的野蛮人，无辜、赤裸、友好、你知道的那种人们遇到的角色；而另一方面，则是某种野蛮的野蛮人的概念。他们会吃掉你。我们甚至根本不知道加勒比人是否会，你知道的，我的意思是，他们可能真的会。我的意思是，对此感到困惑——我的意思是，人们很容易说这纯粹是他捏造的，这是欧洲黑暗幻想等的投射。
But he has no interest in saying that to his sponsors, does he? Probably not. Although it's possible that Columbus tries to make sense of what is happening to him by projecting his emotions onto the indigenous people that he encounters. Perhaps. but equally, you might say that the people who are telling him about this, his hosts, maybe they have an interest in making their neighbors seem as bad as possible. Of course. One of the things that doesn't often get captured, I think, in the accounts of European encounters with the indigenous peoples of the Americas is how much the Europeans are being used. So that's definitely the case in the autumn when we do the conquest of Mexico. That is definitely
但他对赞助者说这种话没有什么好处，不是吗？可能没有。尽管有可能哥伦布试图通过将自己的情绪投射到他遇到的土耳其（原住民）身上来理解正在发生的事情。也许吧。但同样，你也可以说，向他讲述这些事情的人，也就是他的主人，也许他们有动机把他们的邻居描绘得尽可能糟糕。当然。我认为，在欧洲人与美洲原住民接触的叙述中，经常没有被捕捉到的一点是，欧洲人被利用得有多深。所以在秋天我们做墨西哥征服史的时候，这绝对是
the case with Cortes and the conquistadors, that they are being used to some extent by the people they meet. Because he's firing off guns and all kinds of things. And this is obviously of interest to native princes who could immediately see that this might be quite useful. Absolutely. But Columbus is also very conscious. His voyage was not done as a sort of intellectual exercise. It was done to make money. Yeah.
科尔特斯（Cortes）和征服者们的真实写照，他们在某种程度上被他们遇到的人利用了。因为他在开枪，还有各种各样的东西。这显然引起了当地王公们的兴趣，他们一眼就能看出这可能相当有用。绝对是的。但哥伦布也非常清醒。他的航行并不是作为某种智力练习来完成的。它是为了赚钱而进行的。是的。
He has backers, First Antoinette and Isabella, the Genoese. That's why I think it's unlikely that he's just made up the stuff about the cannibals, don't you think but it also means tom that he is behaving as in inverted commas badly from the beginning so his men are seizing things he's interested in taking slaves he's interested in the gold he is desperate actually and and this will be a theme right through this the story of his four voyages he is absolutely desperate to to show a return for the investment um so hence taking captives hence looking for gold he has a very bad blow on christmas eve so he's still there and hispaniola and the largest of his ships the santa maria is wrecked on a reef it was he'd left a ship's boy, he says, in charge, and it all went wrong. Of course, it's the ship's boy.
他有金主，也就是斐迪南和伊莎贝拉，热那亚人。这就是为什么我认为他不太可能是凭空捏造关于食人族的事情，你不觉得吗？但这同时也意味着，汤姆，从一开始他的行为在引号里就是“糟糕的”：所以他的手下在抢夺东西，他有兴趣掠夺奴隶，他对黄金感兴趣，他实际上非常绝望——这将是他四次航行故事中一直贯穿的主题——他绝对渴望为投资带来回报。因此才要抓俘虏，因此才要在寻找黄金。他在平安夜遭遇了沉重打击：当时他还在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛，他最大的船——圣玛丽亚号（Santa Maria）在暗礁上搁浅了。这是因为他留了一个船童，据他说，负责看管，结果全搞砸了。当然，这就是那个船童。
Somebody else's fault. It's very Captain Pugwash behavior. I mean, that will mean nothing to our overseas listeners, but Captain Pugwash blaming everybody but himself. Anyway, the ship is wrecked. And now Columbus does something that was absolutely never part of the plan he doesn't have enough ships to take everybody home so he says i will found a town here and some of the people will stay and say it's the plot of many a science fiction film isn't it yeah i suppose it is actually yes crashed on a distant planet yeah we can't all get back some of us will have to establish a base. Yeah. And this is what they do.
这得怪别人。这非常像“船长帕格沃什”（Captain Pugwash）的行径。我的意思是，这对我们的海外听众来说毫无意义，但船长帕格沃什总是怪罪所有人就是不怪自己。无论如何，船触礁了。现在，哥伦布做了一件绝对不在计划之中的事：他没有足够的船把所有人都带回家，所以他说：我要在这里建立一个小镇，一部分人将留下来。——这可以说是很多科幻电影的情节，不是吗？——对，我想确实是的，流落在一个遥远的星球上，对吧。我们不能全部回去，我们中的一些人必须建立一个基地。是的。他们就是这么做的。
It's La Navidad, the nativity. So it's Christmas Day. They decide to set it up. So he has 39 men. And he says, this is the first European town ever established in the Americas. I mean, how do they choose? Well, the guy who speaks Arabic and Hebrew is one of the people he leaves. Well, of course.
这就是纳维达德（La Navidad），即圣诞节。所以正是圣诞节那天。他们决定建立它。所以他有39个人。他说，这是美洲建立的第一个欧洲城镇。我的意思是，他们是怎么选出来的？嗯，那个会说阿拉伯语和希伯来语的家伙就是他留下的人之一。嗯，理所当然。
I mean, they might run into some Arabs. And a doctor. There's a guy who's a doctor. That makes sense. I wouldn't volunteer for that, though. No. I'd be straight back on that ship. You would, wouldn't you?
我的意思是，他们可能会遇到一些阿拉伯人。还有一个医生。有个家伙是个医生。这倒说得通。不过我可不会自愿去。不会的。我会直接回到那艘船上。你会的，对吧？
But maybe you think, well, but will we be able to get back? Maybe it's better to stay on dry land. I don't know. Every option seems bad. I wouldn't have gone on a voyage, Tom. No. I'll put my cards on the table right now. But with your mastery of rigging and sa that would be a great loss i'd be one of those monks giving advice from one of
但也许你会想，好吧，不过我们能回去吗？也许留在旱地上更好。我不知道。每一个选择看起来都很糟糕。汤姆，我才不会去航海呢。不会的。我现在就把我的底牌亮出来。但是凭借你对 rigging（船具装配）和 sa——那将是一个巨大的损失，我会成为那些在后排指手画脚的修士之一，你知道的，上啊上啊——完全没错，我就会是那样的人。这太棒了。所以他留下了这39个人，然后他说：剩下的人，我们回去吧。正如他的运气所愿，事实上就在1月6日，他们刚一出发，就碰上了马丁·平松和平塔号，也就是那些之前离开的人，他们一直在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛附近航行。平松说：我弄到了一些黄金，而且他还——弄到了一些香料。是的。他弄到了一些辣椒和肉桂。所以他们确实有所收获。平松说：我们跟当地人聊过——天知道是怎么聊的——他们告诉我们附近有珍珠渔场。所以这都是天大的好消息。黄金和香料可以说是必不可少的，对吧？因为如果他们没有黄金，
those backseat driver friars you know go on go on exactly that's what i would be it's gonna be great so he leaves the 39 and he says the rest of us let's go back and his luck would have it actually on the 6th of january just after they've set off, they bump into Martin Pinzon and the Pinta, the people who had gone off, who have been sailing around Hispaniola. And Pinzon says, I've got some gold and he's also- Got some spices. Yeah. He's got some chili and he's got some cinnamon. So they actually have something. And Pinzon says, we've spoken to natives, God knows how, who tell us that there are pearl fisheries nearby. So this is all great news. The gold and the spices are kind of essential, aren't they? Because if they didn't have gold,
如果他们没有带回西班牙的香料，可能整件事都会被勾销。人们不会对它感兴趣。我想是这样的。我的意思是，显然欧洲人在未来的某个时间点可能还是会横渡大西洋，但西班牙人不会马上派遣更多的船只回来。他们会说这是一次彻头彻尾的血本无归。这路途实在太遥远了。所以他们走走停停。他们停下来补充补给之类。
if they didn't have spices to take back to Spain, probably the whole thing would be written off. People wouldn't be interested in it. I think that's right. I mean, obviously Europeans would probably have crossed the Atlantic at some future date, but the Spanish would not have sent back more voyages straight away. They'd have said this was a complete dead loss. It's an awful long way to go. So they're sort of stopping and starting. They're stopping for supplies and things.
就在他们真正启程横渡大西洋之前，他们最终与原住民发生了第一次真正的冲突。为什么？我们其实并不知道。那是1月13日。很有可能是哥伦布一行人正在寻找更多的奴隶带回去，而当地的泰诺人则在进行自卫。他们有弓箭之类的武器，这就是哥伦布进行投射的那种情况，因为在那时他说：这些人一定是食人族。
And just before they really set off across the Atlantic, they end up having their first fight, proper fight, with indigenous people. Why? We don't really know. It's the 13th of January. It's quite possible that columbus and co are looking for more slaves to take back with them um and that the the locals the tainos are defending themselves they have bows and arrows and things and this is this thing about what columbus projecting because at that point he says well these people must have been cannibals
这就是所有那些骇人听闻的事情的来源：关于这些人如何攻占一个村庄，杀光所有的男人，把女人抓走，吃掉她们。不，抱歉，他们会带走女人。是的。让她们生育，抚养孩子，阉割男孩，然后像养农场动物一样把他们养大，接着吃掉他们。是的。我想现在大多数历史学家都认为事实并非如此。
this is where all the kind of gruesome stuff about how these are people who capture, you know, they capture a village, they'll kill all the men, they'll take the women, eat them. No, sorry, they'll take the women. Yes. Breed them, raise the children, castrate the boys and kind of grow them up like farm animals and then devour them. Yes. And I think most historians now think this is not the case.
他们认为这是哥伦布捏造的。是的。我的意思是……食人族抓走儿童并将他们阉割，正如我们给准备养肥端上餐桌的鸡和猪做阉割一样。是的。但再次说明，这……
They think Columbus is inventing this. Yes. I mean... The cannibals capture children whom they castrate just as we neuter chickens and pigs, which we wish to fatten for the table. Yeah. But again, this is...
正如一位历史学家所说，这就造成了这样一种观念：任何反抗西班牙人的原住民都是食人族。这就是西班牙人在接下来几十年里的行为方式。总之，他们回程了。天气好了一段时间。但接着在2月5日，不出意料地，他们遇到了一场风暴，平塔号和尼娜号（Niña）失散了。
So as one historian says, this creates the idea that any native who resists the Spaniards is a cannibal. And this is how the Spaniards will behave in the next few decades. So anyway, back they go. The weather is okay for a while. But then on the 5th of February, they run into a storm, not terribly surprisingly, and they are split up, the Pinta and the Niña.
所以哥伦布一行人最终来到了亚速尔群岛（Azores）。亚速尔群岛属于葡萄牙人。他们是——一行人最终来到了亚速尔群岛，而亚速尔群岛属于葡萄牙人。他们一上岸就被逮捕了。说来也巧，哥伦布手下的10个人上了岸，因为他们想向圣母谢恩以祈求救赎。他们立刻被葡萄牙人逮捕了，葡萄牙人实际上把他们送回了里斯本，那是最近的港口。从哥伦布的角度来看，这又是一件非常糟糕的事，因为首先，这意味着落入了西班牙最大竞争对手的手中。但同时，对于那些本来就不信任哥伦布的西班牙人来说，因为他是个外国人，
So Columbus and Co, they end up in the Azores. And the Azores are owned by the Portuguese. And they are Co, they end up in the Azores, and the Azores are owned by the Portuguese. And they are arrested when they go ashore. So funny enough, 10 of Columbus's men go ashore because they want to give thanks to the Virgin for their salvation. They're immediately arrested by the Portuguese, and the Portuguese effectively send them back to Lisbon, which is the nearest port. This is, again, very bad from Columbus's point of view, because first of all, it means he's in the hands of Spain's big competitor. But also, for Spanish people who distrust Columbus anyway, because he's a foreigner,
这提供了弹药，因为他们会说：瞧，他一直暗中为葡萄牙人效力。他根本信不过。看，他在回到我们这里之前先回了里斯本。我的意思是，有些葡萄牙编年史家说，实际上葡萄牙朝臣曾告诉他们的国王杀了哥伦布。别让他告诉西班牙人，我们自己去宣布占领它。对此我不太确定，因为我认为葡萄牙人从来对美洲不怎么感兴趣，因为他们从那里（指其他地方）赚了太多钱。而且，这也太具有挑衅性了吧？确实会。是的，完全如此。总之，他终于在3月15日回到了帕洛斯-德拉夫罗特拉（Palos de la Frontera）。通过一个离奇的巧合，马丁·平松的船在同一天回到了这里。平松在航行中——大概是因为梅毒——去世了。
this gives them ammunition because they say, oh, he's always secretly been working for the Portuguese. He can't be trusted. Look, he went back to Lisbon before he came back to us. I mean, there are some Portuguese chroniclers who say that actually the Portuguese courtiers told their king to kill Columbus. Don't let him tell the Spaniards and let's go and claim it for ourselves. I'm not sure about that because I think the Portuguese are never really interested in the Americas because they're making so much money from there. Also, it would be such a provocation, wouldn't it? It would. Yeah, exactly. So anyway, he gets back finally to palos de la frontera on the 15th of march by a bizarre coincidence martin pindon's ship gets back on the same day pinzon has has died probably of syphilis
所以他得了梅毒这件事，我的意思是，这倒也不是非常……但也意味着，这对于哥伦布塑造叙事、掌控叙事的能力至关重要。是的，因为否则他们可能会为究竟是谁真正负有责任、究竟是谁找到了最好的东西而争吵不休。但没有人能反驳他。所以哥伦布归来的消息传播得极快。3月中旬就有关于它的信件在书写了。这是一个写信给他位于米兰的兄弟的人。他说他横渡了海洋。
on the on the voyage so the fact that he's got syphilis, I mean, that's not terribly... But also, I mean, crucial also for Columbus's ability to shape the narrative, to control the narrative. Yes, because otherwise they would probably have bickered about which one of them was really responsible and actually found the best things and all this. But nobody can contradict him. So Columbus, news of his return spreads very quickly. There are letters being written about it in the middle of March. This is a guy who's writing to his brother in Milan. He says he sailed across the ocean.
在33天里，他抵达了一个大岛，那里的居民皮肤呈橄榄色，赤身裸体四处走动，毫无好战之意。于是这个消息在传播。这是一个识字的时代。许多人会读会写，还有印刷术。所以消息传播得很快。没错。但他们认为哥伦布找到了什么？我的意思是，对此人们很困惑，不是吗？或者有分歧？嗯，实际上，你知道吗？确实有分歧，但分歧存在于哥伦布和所有其他人之间。并不是人们自己内部有什么分歧。所以大多数人认为他找到了对极大陆（Antipodes）。
In 33 days, he arrived at Great Island where there were inhabitants whose skin was the color of olives going about naked with no disposition to fight. And so this is spreading. This is a literate age. Lots of people can read and write, printing. So the news is spreading quickly. Right. But what do they think Columbus has found? I mean, there is confusion on this, isn't there? Or disagreement? Well, actually, do you know what? There is disagreement, but the disagreement is between Columbus and everybody else. It's not the people among themselves. So most people think he's found the Antipodes.
是的。大多数人说，很显然，希腊人关于存在一个对极大陆的观点是正确的，他找到了一些我们显然在后来会称之为美洲的地方，因为这显然不可能是中国或日本，更不用说印度了。哥伦布绝对坚信他找到了印度，但当然，“印度”这个说法很模糊。它充满暗示性，不是吗？对，它暗示着在某种程度上，在他人脑海的某个角落里，尽管他不肯向自己承认，我想他一定知道这并不是他所预期的。
Yes. Most people say, clearly, the Greek idea that there was an Antipodean continent is correct, that he has found something that actually we will obviously later call America, because this patently cannot be China or Japan, let alone India. Columbus is absolutely adamant that he has found the Indies, but of course the formula, the Indies, is vague. It's suggestive, isn't it? Yeah, it suggests that at some point, I mean, in some part of his mind, even though he doesn't admit it to himself, I think he must know that this is not what he was expecting.
无论如何，他最终来到了巴塞罗那。街道上挤满了人。人们欣喜若狂。人们就是喜欢节日之类的活动。国王和王后接见了。他送给他们羽毛头饰，不是吗？他向他们呈献了辣椒、红薯、黄金。但最关键的是，他呈献了他的人。
Anyway, he ends up in Barcelona. The streets are crowded. People are delighted. People love a festival and stuff. The king and queen receive him. He gives them feathered headdresses, doesn't he? He presents them with chilies, with sweet potatoes, with gold. But the crucial thing, he he presents with his people.
在他带回船上的七个人中，有一个已经死了，还剩下六个泰诺人。他们受了洗。王室夫妇成了他们的教父教母。其中一个人最终成了一个侍童，但他们可能很快都死于疾病。你可以想象那种不仅仅是疾病，还有文化冲击——文化冲击——我刚才正要说同样的话——对于他们我们知之甚少，我们实在无法真正体会到他们当时的想法，
So of the seven people that I think he's brought back on his ship, one is dead and there are six remaining Tainos. They are baptized. The royal couple act as their godparents. One of them ends up becoming a page, but they probably all die very quickly of disease. And you would imagine of a kind of not just disease culture shock culture shock i was just gonna say exactly the same thing just a we know so little about them it's impossible really for us to get any
因为他们显然没有留下任何记录；如果你倾向于像许多听众所知道的那样，把哥伦布视为历史上的一个大恶人，那么这对这些人的影响一定具有绝对毁灭性的打击，他们被强行扯离了他们的岛屿生活，被带回大洋彼岸。尽管哥伦布大概觉得自己是在帮他们一个大忙，因为他把他们带向了基督的光辉。毫无疑问他是这么想的，当时西班牙的所有人也都是这么想的，我想象这些人会觉得
sense of what they must have thought um because they've left obviously no no records um and if you're predisposed as many listeners know that will be to see columbus as a great villain of history the effect on these people must have been absolutely devastating to be wrenched out of their island life and brought back across the ocean although columbus presumably feels that he's doing them a great favor because he's bringing them to the light of christ he undoubtedly thinks that and everybody in spain thinks that at that point i would imagine that these people This is a tremendous moment for these people. They should be terribly grateful. They're being brought into the bosom of
这是一个极其重大的时刻。他们应该心怀极大的感激。他们被带入了救世主的怀抱，诸如此类的话。所以哥伦布的兴趣在于大肆吹嘘。他说这个地方到处都是肉桂，到处都是香料。他带来——我将能够给二位陛下带来你们想要的全部黄金。我们是不是应该以他对此的记述来结尾？应该的。汤姆，你显然很想读一读。我确实想。因为我认为它完美地阐明了那种宗教狂热与贪婪的混合体，这将不仅成为哥伦布余下职业生涯的特征，而且人们可能会认为，这也将成为未来几个世纪欧洲扩张的特征。所以他写到他带回的一切——大黄、肉桂、所有这些东西。他说，整个基督教世界都会欣喜若狂，
the savior, all this sort of stuff. So Columbus, his interest is in overselling it. He says the place is full of cinnamon, full of spices. He bring, I will be able to bring your highnesses all the gold you could want. Shall we end with what he wrote about that? Do. You clearly want to read it, Tom. I do. Because I think it beautifully illustrates the kind of, the mixture of religiosity and avarice that will characterize not just the rest of Columbus's career, but people might argue centuries of European expansion to come. So he's writing about everything that he's brought back, rhubarb, cinnamon, all this kind of stuff. And he says that all Christendom will be delighted
因为我们的救赎主在这件大事上把胜利赐给了我们最杰出的国王和王后以及他们声名远扬的王国。他们应当举行庆祝活动，并向三位一体致以庄严的感谢，伴以许多庄严的祈祷，为了由于如此众多的人民皈依我们的信仰以及随之而来的世俗利益而取得的伟大功绩。因为不仅是西班牙，整个基督教世界都将获得鼓舞和利益。多米尼克，说到鼓舞和利益，你有什么临别寄语要对我们的听众说吗？嗯，汤姆，如果你——我是对听众说，汤姆，不是对你——如果听众在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上注册订阅“历史的其余部分”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club），他们就可以进行免费试用。
that our Redeemer has given triumph to our most illustrious king and queen and their renowned kingdoms in this great matter. They should hold celebrations and render solemn thanks to the Holy Trinity with many solemn prayers for the great feat which they will have by the conversion of so many peoples to our faith and for the temporal benefits which will follow. For not only Spain, but all Christendom will receive encouragement and profit. And Dominic, talking of encouragement and profit, do you have a parting message for our listeners? Well, Tom, you will receive encouragement and profit if you, I'm talking to the listeners, Tom, not to you, if the listeners sign up to the Rest Is History Club subscription on Apple Podcasts, they can do their free trial.
或者，当然，他们可以访问 restishistorypod.com。我知道大家永远不会厌倦在每集节目结束时听到这种极力推销。如果你注册订阅“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，你将获得肉桂、辣椒、红薯和各种各样的福利。但最关键的是，你将比其他所有人提前听到接下来的两集节目。因为，汤姆。无广告。无广告。这，是的——除了我们自己的自我推销当然无处可逃。因为这只是哥伦布在新世界故事的开始。未来还有三次航行。
Or, of course, they can go to restishistorypod.com. I know people are never tired of hearing the hard sell at the end of the episodes. You will receive cinnamon, chilies, sweet potatoes, all kinds of benefits if you sign up to the Rest Is History Club. But crucially, you'll hear the next two episodes before everybody else. Because, Tom. Ad-free. Ad-free. This is, yes, except for our own self-promotion, of course, from which there is no escape. Because this is just the beginning of Columbus's story in the new world. There are three voyages to come.
而在这些航行中，他们为欧洲人参与美洲事务乃至与世界其他地区交往这一充满争议的故事奠定了如此多的基础。多米尼克，我们仍然要讨论今天人们是如何看待哥伦布的，以及对他的两极分化的看法。是的。所以还有很多内容要讲。所以请务必加入我们。非常感谢大家的收听。
And in those voyages, they lay the foundations of so much of the controversial story of European engagement in the Americas and indeed with the rest of the world. And Dominic, we still have the discussion about how Columbus is seen today, the polarised opinions of him. Yes. So lots more still to come. So do please join us. Thanks very much for listening.
再见。再见。再见。聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及少许八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外番外集以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。再见。聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有每周的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的节目、收听额外单集并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。